a look at iran's role in the middle east
and now a panel discussion on israel's
washington lobby and its influence on
u.s policy in the middle east the
council on american islamic relations is
hosting this event it's about 90 minutes
all right and if anybody everybody can
take their seats we'll get started
momentarily
fantastic
all right
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is corey saylor i'm the government
affairs director for the council on
american islamic relations
our panel today is the israel lobby and
the u.s response to the war in lebanon
our discussion will be about u.s support
for israel and the consequences that
result for our nation particularly in
light of the war on terror
our panel features two main speakers
professor stephen walt of harvard
university and professor john mirsheimer
of the university of chicago
their recent paper and article was
published in the london review of books
and it raises questions about the power
of the israel lobby has on u.s foreign
policy
that article was subsequently also a
cover story in the july august issue of
foreign policy magazine
i'll give a little bit more of bios for
each of them right before we introduce
them but we'd like to get straight to
the program a couple of points for
business everyone was handed cards when
they came in more than one if you'd like
but please fill up put your questions on
that someone will and pass them to the
edges someone will come down pick them
up and we'll try to group them together
by theme
we would also like to extend our sincere
thanks and appreciation to dr mohamed
nimmer who is the gentleman who
organized this panel today
how the panel will proceed we will hear
some introductory remarks from the
executive director of the council on
american islamic relations mr nihadawad
he'll speak for about five minutes
and then each of the professors will
speak for about 20 minutes and then
we'll start the question and answer
session and if you'd like more
information about this topic and other
topics on similar issues we'd invite you
to visit our website at care.com
so without further ado i'd like to
introduce mr nihadawad he is the
executive director of the council on
american islamic relations
thank you corey
good afternoon
my name is nihad awad the executive
director of the
council on american islamic relations
care
care is america's largest islamic civil
liberties and advocacy group with 32
offices across the united states and
canada
our vision is to be a leading advocate
for justice and mutual understanding
care's mission is to enhance
understanding of islam encourage
dialogue protect civil liberties
empower american muslims and build
coalitions that promote justice and
mutual understanding
on behalf of cair i would like to
welcome you all to today's important and
timely panel with two distinguished
professors and experts on international
affairs
with the recent war in the middle east
we believe that there is no more timely
and relevant discussion than the one we
have co-sponsored uh sponsored today
with professors
mirsheimer and walt
the tragic conflict that recently
transpired in lebanon and continues in
gaza
has become a catastrophe for innocent
civilians in the region and for
america's credibility
more than 1 000 civilians were killed on
both sides
with the vast majority of deaths
occurring in lebanon
hundreds of thousands of
lebanese civilians were made homeless
and that nation's civilian
infrastructure was devastated by
systematic bombing campaign using
american taxpayers supplied weapons
even today
civilians made civilians many children
are being killed and injured by cluster
bombs dropped on civilian areas in
lebanon in an apparent violation of
agreements with the united states
a report by human rights watch issued
during the conflict stated
quote the israeli government claims it
is taking all possible measures to
minimize civilian harm
but the cases documented here reveal
systematic failure by the idf to
distinguish between combatants and
civilians end quote the executive deputy
secretary general of amnesty
international stated recently quote
israel is assertion that the attacks on
infrastructure were lawful is manifestly
wrong
many of the violations identified in our
report are war crimes end quote
in order to understand the totality
of america's foreign policy response to
this conflict we feel that it is
important to analyze the impact of the
israel lobby on our political process
and response to the war
people all over the muslim world from
palestine and lebanon to indonesia and
morocco question
why american government offers
unconditional support for israel and its
occupation and humiliation of its
neighbors
they ask why why there is an automatic
and uncritical defense of israel even
when it defies international law and
american laws
our one-sided support for israel is the
liability in the war on terror
it has turned much of the world
including our european allies against us
it is time for our mideast policy to
reflect
views held by the majority of americans
who desire a just and peaceful
resolution that preserves the rights
security and dignity of christians
muslims and jews living in the middle
east
our polling indicates
that nearly two-thirds 63 percent of
those who were surveyed favor american
neutrality or disengagement from the
middle east conflict
we believe that only through an honest
dialogue on the influence of the
strongest foreign lobby our country has
ever seen can we help to formulate a
more just and fair foreign policy for
all people in the world
america's middle east policy
which should be based on our nation's
interest
not on those of a powerful domestic
lobby
for a foreign government
it is possible for people in the middle
east and the larger muslim world to
regain their respect for america and to
view to view it as credible
when it calls for
human rights and democracy for all
people
it is also possible to build a middle
east in which all people muslim
christians and jews coexist in an
atmosphere of mutual respect
to achieve that noble goal
we should have the courage to assess and
change our policies toward the region
and to maintain
that there should be one standard for
defining terrorism and the human the
value of human life
before we begin the panel discussion
allow me to recognize a pioneer in
promoting america's interest in the
middle east
former congressman paul findley
former congressman paul findley who
served the nation for 22 years
for a long time congressman paul findlay
supported our uncritical stance in favor
of israel
that is until he went to the region and
saw with his own eyes
the level of suffering resulting from
that policy
he ultimately wrote two groundbreaking
books
on the subject they dare to speak out
and another book
deliberate deception
mr findlay's books were not popular when
they
were published especially they dare to
speak about they they there to speak out
about 20 some years ago
it was an eye-opener for me
and millions of americans
who started to understand the influence
of the israel lobby on our foreign
policy
i urge people to read this book and
communicate with their members of
congress
they should also have the courage to
make decisions on behalf of america
and to serve america's interest fairs
and not israel
now i will turn the discussion back to
cory saylor our government affairs
director thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much nihad our first
speaker is professor john mearsheimer he
is
our first speaker
is professor stephen walt
he is international affairs at harvard
university he got his phd in political
science from the university of
california berkeley
previously on the faculties of both
princeton and the university of chicago
and with no further ado sir
thank you very much uh it's a pleasure
to be here today and i want to thank
care for inviting us to present the
results of our research on the forces
that shape u.s middle east policy i
think this is an important subject for
all americans and for all of the
countries in the middle east as well
our presentation is going to be in two
parts i'm going to begin by summarizing
the main arguments in our article on the
israel lobby and then john will apply
those ideas to the recent war between
israel and lebanon and show that you
can't really understand what happened
there if you don't understand the
political power of pro-israel groups in
the united states our bottom line as
many of you know is that the influence
of the israel lobby has led to policies
that are not in the u.s national
interest
not in the interests of other countries
in the region and ultimately not in
israel's long-term interest as well
we're going to try and limit our remarks
to about 25 minutes apiece so there is
time for comments and questions when
we're done
all right what's our core argument we
make several big arguments in our paper
uh first we just document the level of
support the united states provides to
israel about three billion dollars a
year
in economic and military assistance each
year that's about 500 per year per
israeli citizen despite the fact that
israel is a relatively wealthy
industrial power
that aid is largely unconditional it's
not linked to israeli behavior it gets
its aid when it builds settlements it
gets its aid when it spies on us when it
sells american high technology to
countries like china or when it attacks
civilians in the west bank lebanon or
gaza
israel also gets consistent diplomatic
support from the united states since
1982 for example
we have vetoed 33 u.n security council
resolutions that were critical of israel
that's a total greater than all of the
vetoes by all of the other security
council members put together
and finally we take israel's side in
wartime as john is going to discuss in
some detail
moreover over time we have tended to
favor israel's side whenever peace talks
do occur
this led former u.s negotiator aaron
miller to state a few years back that
the united states basically had acted as
israel's lawyer during the oslo process
and of course has been even more
one-sided under president bush
bottom line here is no other country
gets the same level of economic military
and diplomatic support
now that support is usually justified by
saying that israel is a vital strategic
asset or by invoking various moral
rationales
we argue in our paper that this level of
support can't be fully explained by
either strategic or moral arguments
with respect to the strategic argument
israel may have been a useful ally
during the cold war
it's possible to make a pretty good
argument on that basis but the soviet
union is now gone the cold war is over
and we don't face any great power rivals
today israel is said to be a key ally in
the war on terror and in our efforts to
combat rogue states like syria and iran
but there are several big problems with
this line of argument
first it has the causal logic backwards
we don't back israel because we have a
common threat from terrorism rather we
have a common threat from terrorism
because we have been so closely tied to
israel that's not again let me be very
clear here that's not the only reason i
am not saying that our unconditional
support for israel is the only source of
anti-american terrorism but it is a very
important one this was clearly stated in
the 9 11 commission report
this was the conclusion reached by
separate studies by the u s state
department and by the pentagon's defense
of science board in the last couple of
years
numerous surveys of arab public opinion
confirmed their strong resentment at
unconditional american support for
israel and if you go to our
enemy bin laden and look at his
statements it's quite clear that
our support for israel has been an issue
for him for quite some time again not
the only source of anti-american
extremism
but it is an important one
second although the united states does
have some differences with other
countries in the region israel turns out
to be the main bone of contention
between us and them
for example last year president bush
said we didn't want iran to get nuclear
weapons not because it threatened to
attack the united states but quote
because it would threaten our ally
israel
there are a lot of good reasons why the
united states doesn't want countries in
that region to get weapons of mass
destruction but we shouldn't overstate
that particular danger remember those
states could not use any wmd without
being destroyed in retaliation and that
also means that threatening to use them
wouldn't be very credible either
finally israel's own nuclear arsenal is
one reason why other countries in that
area want them and it makes it harder
for us to put pressure on states that
are trying to get them
third and perhaps most important israel
isn't much of a strategic asset for
dealing with those problems for example
it could not participate in the 1990-91
gulf war or the more recent 2000 gulf
war in fact in both cases the united
states had to divert military assets to
protecting israel
the bottom line here is that
unconditional support for israel makes
winning the war on terrorism harder not
easier there isn't a compelling
strategic rationale for the current
level of u.s aid
what about the moral arguments
there are a set of different moral
arguments justifying american support
for israel because it's said to be
vulnerable surrounded by enemies because
it's the only democracy in the middle
east or because it is said to have acted
much better than its adversaries have
these arguments sound convincing but if
you look at them carefully again they
can't explain why the united states
gives it so much support and so
unconditionally
let me emphasize that john and i both
believe there is a strong moral case for
israel's existence based on the long
history of anti-semitism the tragic
experience of the holocaust and we also
believe the united states should help
protect israel if its survival were in
jeopardy
but israel's existence is fortunately
not in jeopardy it's the dominant
military power in the middle east it has
several hundred nuclear weapons of its
own it is not going to be erased from
the pages of history no matter what some
islamic radicals or what iran's
president might say
and let me be very clear about this john
and i think this is a good thing
israel does have some security problems
but the tap root of those problems is
its failure to achieve a just peace with
the palestinians
israeli defense forces are not all
powerful but hezbollah hamas or iran
couldn't conquer israel today or in the
foreseeable future
what about the rest of the moral case
it's true that israel is a democracy but
that doesn't explain why we give it so
much aid
and so unconditionally there are lots of
democracies in the world but none of
them gets the kind of support that
israel does
and there are some aspects of israeli
democracy that are at odds with core u.s
values the united states is a liberal
democracy a melting pot where all ethnic
and religious groups are supposed to
have equal status
israel on the other hand was explicitly
founded as a jewish state its non-jewish
population is treated as a second-class
citizenship or citizenry it also denies
political rights to the several million
palestinians it has under its control so
israel is a vibrant democracy but only
for part of its people
my point by the way is not to single out
israel for criticism or to say that
israeli democracy is in some way wrong
simply to point out that its democratic
character cannot explain why we give it
so much help
finally one cannot justify u.s support
by claiming that israel has behaved
better than the palestinians i'm not
going to go into the details here but a
fair-minded look at the historical
record shows that both sides have been
guilty of terrorism
of wartime atrocities and a great deal
of brutal behavior
to be clear we think palestinian
terrorism is wrong and that it has been
counterproductive
but the zionists also use terrorism in
their own struggle to gain a state and
israel's treatment of its palestinian
subjects today is morally indefensible
and you don't have to take my word for
it just ask respected human rights
organizations like save the children
human rights watch amnesty international
or the israeli group betslem
and plenty of israelis including former
heads of shin bet israel's domestic
security organization would agree with
that
now once again we are not saying that
israel has acted worse than other
countries have but neither has it acted
any better and one cannot explain u.s
support on this basis so how are we to
explain it the answer is the political
influence of the israel lobby
we define the lobby as a loose coalition
of individuals and groups who work to
shape u.s policy in a pro-israel
direction
it is not a centralized movement with a
single headquarters there are lots of
differences within different
organizations in it
it is not synonymous with american jews
because many american jews don't care
that much about israel others don't
support the lobby's positions and some
of the groups that work powerfully on
israel's behalf like christian zionists
are not jewish
it is not a cabal a conspiracy and
there's nothing improper or illegitimate
about its activities it's just a good
old-fashioned american special interest
group and those interest groups are a
central part of american political life
so how does it work and why is it so
powerful well again in the united states
given the way our government is
organized small groups with a very
focused agenda often wield lots of
political power because they care a lot
because they work 24 7 and because they
hold crucial swing votes if the rest of
the population is largely indifferent
those with a single focus can get their
way despite being relatively small in
number think of the power of the farm
lobby even though farmers are less than
two percent of the american population
think of the national rifle association
think about other ethnic lobbies such as
cuban americans
second the israel lobby is particularly
well funded and effective aipac's annual
budget is almost 50 million it has a
large full-time staff regional offices
around the country
they're very good at steering campaign
contributions to political candidates
either to reward people who are
pro-israel or to penalize people who are
regarded as suspect groups and
individuals in the lobby write articles
letters op-eds defending the u.s israel
relationship
representatives of these groups talk
directly to legislators help draft
legislation meet with other government
officials
and in general
work overtime to shape public discourse
in the united states so that israel is
viewed favorably by most americans this
turns out to be easy to do because most
mainstream media are strongly pro-israel
for example it's hard to think of any
prominent pundit or commentator who's
strongly critical of israel or strongly
pro-arab but it's easy to think of lots
of commentators who are openly
pro-israel
finally groups in the lobby are quick to
attack and smear anyone who criticizes
israel israel's policies or criticizes
u.s support
and other pro-israel groups organized
boycotts and blacklists against media
organizations that might report
something negative about israel they put
pressure on universities to marginalize
anyone who's critical
and finally as most of you know if
you're in washington most of the major
district of columbia-based think tanks
like the washington institute for near
east policy the american enterprise
institute heritage foundation brookings
institute all tilt in israel's direction
there are other more smaller and more
specialized groups they're even more
extreme in that way
for all of these reasons the israel
lobby is quite powerful and this is no
secret uh aipac was ranked number two
number two in the national journals
survey of lobbies in march 2005 tied
with the aarp by the way and it was
ranked also ranked second in a 1997
survey by forbes magazine
uh bill clinton said aipac was quote
better than anyone else lobbying in this
town newt gingrich said it was quote the
most effective general interest group
across the entire planet
former senator fritz hollings said as he
was leaving office
you can't have an israel policy other
than what aipac gives you around here
and it's no surprise therefore that
israeli prime minister echoed olmert
recently said thank god we have aipac
the greatest supporter and friend we
have in the whole world
now these comments raise an interesting
question
why was our article so controversial
if we were just saying what everybody
already knows
now finally we argued that the lobby had
a powerful and negative effect on us
middle east policy and you just have to
imagine what the world and what u.s
policy might be like if the lobby were
less influential
if the lobby were less powerful
the united states would have used its
leverage over the last 30 years to
discourage the settlements policy or
prevent it completely every american
president since lyndon johnson has
opposed the settlements and declared
them an obstacle to peace but no
president was willing to pay the
political price to stop them instead we
subsidize them and many israelis of
course now understand this was a tragic
mistake they radicalized the palestinian
population encouraged the growth of
islamic extremism cost billions of
dollars and thousands of lives and
undermined israel's image around the
world
so the lobby's influence undermined
israel's security as well as our own
if the lobby were less influential the
united states would have adopted a more
independent policy towards the peace
process instead of acting again as
israel's lawyer now people in the lobby
routinely blame the failure of the peace
process entirely on yasir arafat even
though it's clear of course that the
united states israel and the
palestinians all deserve a share of the
blame for the failure of the oslo
process
but if arafat was the problem why hasn't
the united states done anything to
support mahmoud abbas he's elected in a
democratic election he's recognized
israel rejected terror and called for a
negotiated settlement given all our
problems in the middle east and
especially our deteriorating image in
the arab and islamic world you'd think
we would have jumped on this opportunity
to try and accomplish something
what do we do instead we give
abbas nothing we endorse
further israeli encroachments on the
west bank instead and what's the result
the election of hamas leaving everybody
including israel worse off
if the lobby were less influential the
united states would have been much less
likely to have invaded iraq in 2003
this war was conceived by
neoconservatives many of them connected
in the lobby
encouraged by many israeli leaders and
endorsed openly by groups like aipac
i want to emphasize here the lobby's
influence is not the only reason why the
united states went to war in iraq
indeed the lobby could not get either
clinton or bush to go to war by
themselves even though the
neoconservatives were pushing for it
from the late 1990s onward so we don't
argue that they were singularly
responsible
the key additional factor was september
11th which turned cheney and bush in
favor of war
so without 911 you don't get a war in
iraq either
but remember neoconservatives like paul
wolfowitz in the pentagon were quick to
link saddam hussein to september 11th
even though there was no connection and
key groups in the lobby pushed very hard
to make the case for war so we argue
that the israel lobby was a necessary
though not sufficient condition for the
iraq war without the lobby the war would
have been much less likely
and finally if the lobby were weaker u.s
policy towards iran would have been more
flexible and possibly more effective
for the past decade or more a number of
prominent american experts have called
for a more flexible policy towards iran
but they get nowhere because aipac has
pushed for a hard-line approach iran has
made several overtures to us over the
past decade getting no response they
actually helped us after september 11th
and we rewarded them by putting them in
the axis of evil and calling for regime
change
they sent us a back channel message in
2003 which included a somewhat veiled
offer to end support for hezbollah
possibly recognize israel we rejected
because key groups in the lobby were
adamantly opposed to any opening
what result the iranian hardliners get
stronger ahmadinejad gets elected iran's
nuclear ambitions get reinforced again
the point i want to underscore here is
that in all of these cases our policy
has been bad for the united states and
bad for israel as well
now i want to highlight two things i
didn't say that we didn't say in our
article
we did not say that the israel lobby was
all powerful let me repeat this this is
not some secret cabal that controls our
foreign policy
and there are countervailing forces out
there though they are much weaker and
the lobby doesn't get its way on every
single issue
but nobody who has worked on these
issues in washington would deny that
it's a very effective set of individuals
and organizations and i would argue they
get their way now more than they used to
second we didn't accuse and don't accuse
anyone of being disloyal to the united
states
rather we recognize that all of us have
many commitments and affinities to our
country to our religion to our family
sometimes to our employers
it's entirely permissible for those
different commitments and attachments to
manifest themselves in politics that's
perfectly okay here in the united states
people like paul wolfowitz or doug feith
and people who work for aipac advocate
policies they think are good for israel
and the united states alike
we don't think there's anything wrong
with that but we also don't think
there's anything wrong for others to
point out these individuals do have
attachments that shape how they think
about the middle east and how they think
about american policy in that region
and we see nothing wrong with saying
that the views they think are in our
best interests might not be in america's
best interest or that of israel now
before i sum up i want to make just a
couple of quick comments about the
public reaction to our article
when we wrote it john and i knew it was
likely to be controversial
we were disappointed that much of the
reaction consisted of attacks on our
characters or on extraneous issues
rather than on a serious discussion of
our main arguments as i said before we
really didn't say anything that was all
that
controversial that wasn't common
knowledge inside the beltway and if
you've looked carefully at our paper
you'll note that most of our analysis
relies on controversial sources like the
new york times the washington post the
wall street journal haaretz and forward
as i noted again washington insiders in
both parties are well aware of the
influence that the lobby has
and so it wasn't what we said
it was rather that two card carrying
members of the mainstream foreign policy
establishment with rather impeccable
even boring middle-of-the-road
credentials and absolutely no trace of
an anti-semitic history attitudes or
behavior
finally pointed out the elephant in the
room
so what happened
well there were the predictable
accusations that we were anti-semites
and various attempts to smear us by
associating us with people like david
duke
people who offered these charges gave no
evidence
to back them up of course for the simple
reason that there isn't any evidence
there was lots of attention on a various
extraneous issues such as whether the
kennedy school where i work had asked me
to step down from my position as
academic dean for the record it didn't
when people did discuss the substance
they tended to misrepresent our
arguments or erroneously accused us of
various factual errors now john and i
have already dealt with some of those
charges in a
letter to the london review we are now
preparing a lengthy response to our
critics that will show the various
factual criticisms are without
foundation and it's also worth noting
that most of these criticisms dealt with
secondary issues anyway not with the
main arguments in our book
the most peculiar claim to us was the
claim that we were sloppy
somehow the paper is very sloppy and the
what you want to ask yourself is does
this seem at all likely
john and i have between us written six
books and countless articles
uh people have disagreed with us
throughout our careers but no one has
ever said before that our work was
sloppy
is it credible to think that the two of
us would tackle a third rail issue like
this one
and suddenly decide to be careless and
cavalier in what we did
and i might add the piece was vetted by
a number of other scholars in the field
we sent drafts around to lots of people
to get comments before we published it
to make sure that there were no
meaningful errors in it at all now
finally if you then look at the people
who aren't connected to the lobby
and they take a careful look at the ones
who've taken a look at our claims they
tend to agree with us
michael massing wrote an essay in the
new york review of books where he
repeated unfortunately some of the bogus
charges against the paper but his bottom
line is quite clear and i quote it
quote on their central point the power
of the israel lobby and the negative
effects it has had on u.s foreign policy
mir sharma and walt are entirely correct
similarly el carl brown a distinguished
professor emeritus at princeton recently
wrote in foreign affairs that our paper
was neither sloppy nor anti-semitic
instead he called it a hard-headed
analysis that just might set in motion a
useful paradigm shift in u.s middle east
policy
needless to say we are pleased that the
conversation is starting to focus on
substance
our country faces very serious problems
in the middle east in iraq with iran and
saudi arabia in the tragic conflict
between israel and the palestinians and
we are not going to deal with any of
these problems effectively if we cannot
discuss these issues openly and honestly
and if we can't discuss all of the
factors that influence our policy in the
region
meanwhile outside the beltway and back
in the middle east
there was a growing conflict between the
israel and the palestinians israeli
forces were once again reoccupying gaza
hamas had captured an israeli soldier
and was launching kadusas
and at this point hezbollah ambushed an
israeli patrol near the israeli lebanese
border
which gave israel
the pretext to launch a pre-planned
campaign to eliminate or gravely weaken
hezbollah
as john will now explain this tragic and
unnecessary war provides additional
evidence for how the israel lobby is
shaping u.s policy
and harming the united states israel and
israel's neighbors thank you john
i'd just like to step in and remind
everybody again you have the cards for
questions please write down your
questions pass them to the
aisles and we'll have people come around
and collect them professor john
mearsheimer is a professor at the
university of chicago he graduated from
west point in 1970 and has written
extensively about security issues and
international politics
thank you corey
thank you steve for your excellent
presentation
and introduction
uh
i will proceed by describing the
extensive support that the united states
provided israel during the recent
lebanon war next i will attempt to show
that this support did not make good
strategic sense for the united states
and also that there was no compelling
moral rationale for it
in fact the opposite is the case i will
then argue that the main reason the
united states supported israel
was the lobby
finally i will consider two alternative
arguments
that israelis and their supporters in
this country
sometimes employed to explain america's
unconditional support for israel during
the lebanon conflict specifically i'll
examine the claim that u.s policy
reflects
american public's deep commitment to
israel
as well as the claim that israel was
acting as america's client state in its
war with hezbollah in short i will argue
that the bush administration's policy in
lebanon was not in america's national
interest i might add that i do not think
it was in israel's national interest
either
israel had would have been much better
off if the united states had given it a
red light instead of a green light when
it proposed its a
its plan
to attack lebanon that way israel would
have been forced to come up with a
smarter response and would have avoided
the debacle that ensued in lebanon
american support for israel and lebanon
started when the bush administration
gave israel the okay to try to smash
hezbollah at an opportune moment it now
seems clear that israel had been
planning to strike at hezbollah for
months before the july 12 kidnappings
and that key israelis had briefed the
administration about their intentions
the available evidence indicates that
the bush administration
enthusiastically
endorsed israel's plans for war in
lebanon
once the war began and israel came in
for severe criticism from all around the
world the bush administration provided
israel with diplomatic protection
it vetoed a u.n security council
resolution that criticized israel and it
worked deciduously for about a month to
prevent the un from imposing a
cease-fire
so that israel could try to finish the
job with hezbollah
only when it became apparent that the
idf was not going to win a decisive
victory that the bush administration and
israel accept the need for a ceasefire
during the ensuing negotiations which
resulted in resolution 1701
the united states went to great lengths
to protect israel's interests
in fact as the resolution was being
finalized israeli prime minister ahood
olmert called president bush on august
11 and thanked him for quote
safeguarding israel's interests in the
security council end of quote the
president also frequently defended
israel's actions in public and never
offered a word of criticism john bolton
the u.s ambassador to the u.n defended
israel at every turn during the lebanon
war
finally the administration provided
israel with intelligence during the
conflict
and when israel started running out of
smart bombs the president quickly agreed
to send replacements
it is no surprise that shy feldman an
israeli scholar said quote there is huge
huge appreciation here for the president
congress has long been the place where
israel finds its strongest support in
america and its behavior during the
lebanon conflict confirmed that
situation
democrats and republicans competed to
show that their party not the rival one
was israel's best friend
one jewish activist said that he thought
that quote it's a good thing to have
members of congress outdo their
colleagues by showing their pro-israeli
condensals are stronger than the next
guys
in the end there was virtually no
daylight between the two parties
regarding israel which is quite
remarkable when you think of the sharp
differences between the two parties on
most other important foreign policy
issues like iraq for example in terms of
concrete actions the house of
representatives passed a strongly worded
resolution supporting israeli policy in
lebanon the vote was 410 to eight
the senate unanimously passed a similar
resolution which was sponsored by 62
senators including the leaders of both
parties
a number of prominent democrats
including the party's leaders in both
the house and the senate
tried to prevent iraq's prime minister
from addressing congress
because he had dared to criticize
israeli policy in lebanon
howard dean the chairman of the
democratic party went so far as to say
the iraqi prime minister is an
anti-semite
potential presidential candidates for
2008 like hillary clinton john mccain
joe biden and newt gingrich were falling
all over themselves to express their
support for israel
the only exception to that rule was
senator chuck hagel who expressed mild
reservation about what israel and the
united states were doing in lebanon
one can be sure that he stands zero
chance of becoming the next president of
the united states
the mainstream media also stood firmly
behind israel
editor and publisher a distinguished
journal which covers the newspaper
industry surveyed dozens of newspapers
about a week after the war began
and found that quote almost none of them
have condemned the israeli attack on
civilian areas and the infrastructure of
lebanon the 24 cable 24-hour cable news
stations were filled with reports and
commentary which portrayed israel as a
beleaguered combatant that could do no
wrong
perhaps the situation in the mainstream
media is best summed up by these words
from an article in the independent of
british newspaper quote there are two
sides to every conflict unless you rely
on the u.s media for information about
the battle in lebanon
viewers have been fed a diet of partisan
coverage
which treats israel as the good guys and
their hezbollah enemy as the incarnation
of evil
not only is there next to no debate
but debate itself is considered
unnecessary and suspect
what makes america's overwhelming
support for israel so remarkable is that
the united states was the only country
that enthusiastically supported israel's
actions in lebanon in fact almost every
other country in the world as well as
the un leadership criticized israeli
policy and i might add washington's
unyielding support of israel
this situation
raises the obvious question
why was the united states so out of step
with the rest of the
world one possible answer is that
supporting israel made eminently good
strategic sense for the united states
however that's not the case
the war in lebanon undermined america's
position in the middle east
to be more specific the united states
has three major strategic concerns in
that critically important region
the first is terrorism which is mainly
about neutralizing al qaeda
although the united states is also
committed to dealing with hamas and
hezbollah
the second concern is so-called rogue
states like iran and syria which not
only support terrorism but in the case
of iran seems determined to acquire
nuclear weapons
the third concern is the war in iraq
which the united states is in danger of
losing
the bush administration's support for
israel in the recent lebanon war
complicates washington's ability to deal
with all three of these problems
events in lebanon have complicated
america's terrorism problem in two ways
first it has reinforced anti-americanism
in the arab and islamic world which
surely will help al qaeda find new
recruits who want to attack the united
states and its allies
this increased hostility towards america
will also generate public support for
those terrorists in the middle east and
elsewhere
second the conflict has increased
hezbollah's standing inside and outside
of lebanon
although hezbollah does not directly
threaten the united states washington
has an interest in weakening its
influence in the region
however by supporting israel's offensive
in lebanon it helped make hezbollah
stronger not weaker
the conflict in lebanon has also made it
more difficult to deal with iran and
syria while there is no question that
both countries support hezbollah the
united states has a powerful interest in
weakening or breaking those linkages
as well as breaking the linkage between
iran and syria
instead the bush administration has
blindly supported israel and has treated
hezbollah iran and syria as part of a
seamless web of evil
the result
one iran and syria are more likely to
continue arming and supporting hezbollah
two iran and syria have even more reason
to keep the united states pinned down in
iraq so that it cannot not attack either
of them
three iran has more reason than ever to
acquire nuclear weapons so that it can
deter an israeli or u.s attack on its
homeland
it's also worth noting that the idf's
lackluster performance in lebanon makes
clear that it will not be of much value
in helping the united states deal with
this threat environment which its
actions helped create and continue to
fuel
as steve said israel is not a strategic
asset for dealing with terrorist threats
or rogue states
as noted u.s policy during the lebanon
war has given iran and syria more reason
to do what they can to make life
miserable for the united states
in
iraq
however it also angered iraqis
themselves
especially iraqi shia who feel a
powerful sense of allegiance to
hezbollah because it represents the shia
of southern lebanon
the united states is obviously in deep
trouble in iraq and it cannot afford to
further alienate the local population
but that is what the bush
administration's policy in lebanon did
finally the policy was strategically
foolish because it endangers friendly
regimes in egypt jordan and saudi arabia
and runs the risk of causing a civil war
in lebanon and undoing the cedar
revolution which president bush did so
much to make happen
american policy also angers our allies
in europe and raises doubts about the
whether the united states is a reliable
ally for dealing with the terrorist and
proliferation threats in the middle east
which is much closer to europe than is
the united states and some backing
israel to the hilt in its war with
lebanon was not in america's strategic
interest it is hard to disagree with
aaron miller's observation that quote
there is a danger in a policy in which
there is no daylight whatsoever between
the government of israel and the
government of the united states
one might concede that support for
israel had significant strategic costs
but argued that it was nevertheless the
correct policy for moral reasons
israel so the argument goes has a right
to defend itself and it did so in a way
that conformed to the laws of war
let me address this line of argument
to start there's no question that israel
has the right to defend itself hardly
anyone can test that point and steve and
i certainly do not
the critical issue here is whether
israel's actions were consistent with
the laws of war that's the question on
the table the answer is no the israeli
campaign against lebanon had two
components the first was to destroy
hezbollah as a fighting force special
attention was paid to eliminating the
thousands of missiles and rockets that
it possessed
the second component was a classic
punishment campaign here the aim was to
inflict massive pain on lebanon's
civilian population by destroying
infrastructure and killing civilians
one might think that israel only
initiated its punishment campaign in
response to hezbollah's attacks
on israeli civilians but that would be
wrong
remember how the war started it began on
july 12th when hezbollah fighters killed
three israeli soldiers and captured two
more near the border between israel and
lebanon
israel responded by bombing lebanon
which in turn led hezbollah to launch
rockets and missiles at towns and cities
in northern israel
thus
although hezbollah precipitated the
conflict
israel initiated the deadly
counterpopulation exchanges
israeli leaders made it clear from the
start that all of lebanon would pay a
severe price in the war for example
general dan holutz the israeli chief of
staff said at the beginning of the
conflict that he intended quote to turn
back the clock in lebanon by 20 years he
was also quoted at one point as saying
that quote
nothing is safe in lebanon
and he was true to his word
consider amnesty international's
assessment of what the idf wrought in
lebanon i'm going to read from the
report
during more than four weeks of ground
and area bombardment of lebanon by the
israeli armed forces the country's
infrastructure
suffered destruction on a catastrophic
scale
israeli forces pounded buildings into
the ground reduced entire neighborhoods
to rubble and turned villages and towns
into ghost towns as their inhabitants
fled the bombardments
main roads bridges and petrol stations
were blown to bits entire families were
killed in air strikes on their homes or
in their vehicles while fleeing the
aerial assaults on their villages
scores laid buried beneath the rubble of
their houses for weeks as the red cross
and other rescue workers were prevented
from accessing the areas by continuing
israeli strikes the hundreds of
thousands of lebanese who fled the
bombardment now face the danger of
unexploded munitions as they head home
the israeli air force launched more than
7 000 air attacks on about 7 000 targets
in lebanon between 12 july and 14 august
while the navy conducted an additional 2
500 bombardments
the attacks
although widespread particularly
concentrated on certain areas in
addition to the human toll and here's
the human toll an estimated
1183 fatalities about one-third of whom
were children
4054 people injured and
970 thousand lebanese people displaced
the civilian in structure infrastructure
was severely damaged the lebanese
government estimates that 31 vital
points such as airports
ports water and sewage treatment plants
electrical facilities have been
completely or partially destroyed as
have around 80 bridges and 94 roads more
than 25 fuel stations and around
commercial enterprises were hit the
number of residential properties offices
and shops completely destroyed
exceeds thirty thousand
two government hospitals were completely
destroyed in israeli attacks and three
others were seriously damaged i could go
on but i won't
amnesty
amnesty international is hardly alone in
its assessment of the damage the idf
inflicted in lebanon william arkin an
american security expert and a
self-proclaimed quote unquote fan of air
power wrote in the washington post that
quote in carrying out its punishment
campaign israel has left behind a
shocking level of destruction outside
the direct battle zone i hesitate to use
the words laid to waste and moonscape in
describing the condition in urban
lebanon because the same kinds of words
are thrown around so promiscuously in
describing u.s airstrikes
but what israel has wrought is far more
ruinous than anything the u.s military
specifically the u.s air force has
undertaken in the era of precision
warfare
it seems intuitively clear that israel's
destructive campaign invite in lebanon
violated the laws of war but that's not
enough it's important to understand the
specifics of the case
the bedrock distinction that underpins
the laws of war as well as just war
theory is between civilian and military
targets
there is no question that states have
the right to defend themselves
by attacking each other's military
assets however they are not supposed to
directly attack civilian targets in
another state unless of course they
morph into military targets in the
course of the war
furthermore when attacking an
adversary's military target
targets states must make a determined
effort
to minimize collateral damage this is
where the well-known concept of
proportionality comes into play it says
that when states strike at military
targets they must make sure that there
is not excessive collateral damage given
the particular value of the military
target
in short
states
cannot attack enemy civilian targets on
purpose
and they must take great care to avoid
collateral damage when hitting military
targets
israel for failed to observe either of
these distinctions there's no question
that israel purposely attacked a wide
array of civilian targets in lebanon the
description of the devastation from the
amnesty international report makes this
clear remember it concluded that
lebanon's quote infrastructure suffered
destruction on a catastrophic scale that
report also says at another point that
israel's bombing campaign resulted in
quote massive destruction of civilian
infrastructure end of quote in a
separate study
of israel's offensive in lebanon human
rights watch this is not amnesty
international but human rights watch
concluded that quote israel has violated
one of the most fundamental tenets of
the laws of war the duty to carry out a
tax on only military targets
it's also clear that israel did not take
care to avoid collateral damage when
striking targets that it considered
military in nature indeed human rights
watch concluded that that despite
israel's claims that it was quote taking
all possible measures to minimize
civilian harm end of quotes in fact
there was quote a systematic failure by
the idf to distinguish between
combatants and civilians end of quotes
israel and its supporters invariably
respond to this charge with the claim
that israel may have killed a large
number of innocent civilians but that
was only because hezbollah was using
them as human shields the human rights
watch study that i just referenced
however directly contradicts that claim
to quote from the report human rights
watch found no cases no cases in which
hezbollah deliberately used civilians as
shields to protect them from the
retaliatory idf attacks
in none of the cases of civilian deaths
documented in this report is there
evidence to suggest that hezbollah
forces or weapons were in or near the
area that the idf targeted during or
just prior to the attack
regarding the issue of proportionality
the report also declares that quote the
idf consistently tolerated a high level
of civilian casualties for questionable
military gain
at least one israeli leader made no
bones about the fact that israel was
violating the proportionality principle
dan gillerman israel's ambassador to the
united states said early in the war to
those countries who claim that we are
using disproportionate force i have only
one i have only this to say
you are damn right we are
in some it is impossible to make the
case that the united states supported
israel during the lebanon war
because it was the morally correct
policy choice if morality was the issue
the bush administration would have
condemned israel's action in lebanon
from the start
principle reason of course that the
united states backed israeli policy in
lebanon while the rest of the world
criticized it is the israel lobby
aipac and other organizations in the
lobby worked overtime from start to
finish to make sure that there was no
daylight between american and israeli
policy
four days after the war began nathan
guttmann wrote in the jerusalem post
the american jewish community has been
demonstrating
wall-to-wall support for israel as it
fights on two fronts
pro-israel organizations raised money
for the jewish state took out
advertisements in newspapers closely
monitored the media and met with
legislators and staff on capitol hill
policy makers in the bush administration
and influential media figures they left
no stone unturned there are numerous
examples of the major organizations at
work here are three of them first there
was an effort to temper the house
resolutions supporting israel by
supporting language urging quote all
sides to protect life and infrastructure
congressman nancy pelosi the house
minority leader and senator john warner
among others favored that change in
language one would think that such
language would be unobjectionable if not
welcome
but aipac which was the main driving
force behind the resolution to begin
with objected and john boehner the house
majority leader kept the proposed
language out
the resolution still passed 410 to 8.
second chris
von hollen a congressman a democratic
congressman from maryland wrote a letter
to secretary of state condoleezza rice
on july 30 urging her quote to call for
an immediate cease-fire to be followed
by the rapid deployment of an
international force in southern lebanon
he also wrote that quote the israeli
response has now gone beyond the
destruction of hezbollah's military
assets it has caused huge damage to
lebanon's civilian infrastructure
resulted in the large loss of civilian
life and produced over
750 000 refugees hezbollah is undeniably
the culprit but it is the lebanese
people not hezbollah who are
increasingly the victims of the violence
as a result the israeli bombing campaign
supported by the united states has
transformed lebanese anger at hezbollah
into growing hostility toward israel and
the united states the lobby was furious
with van hollen and quickly moved to
tell the congressman in no uncertain
terms that he should never have written
the letter van hollen met with various
representatives from major jewish
organizations who explained to him the
basic facts of life in american politics
the congressman apologized saying quote
i am sorry if my strong criticism of the
bush administration's failures has been
interpreted as a criticisms of isr as a
criticism of israel's conduct in the
current crisis that certainly was not my
intention
he emphasized that he would continue to
be an advocate for israel and that he
was talking with jewish leaders about
the possibility of traveling to israel
within a few weeks
still the leader of the jewish community
relations council of greater washington
told him that quote he needs to continue
to reach out to the jewish community to
reassure the jewish community he is
going to be there for israel
the adl's regional director for
washington said that as far as he was
concerned van hollen's response quote
doesn't undo the damage of the first
letter
the third example early in the war
president bush gently encouraged israel
to be careful not to topple the
democratically elected government in
lebanon which the president had helped
put in power
the lobby took issue with bush
and sent him the message that it
considered his rhetoric unacceptable
for example the jewish newspaper forward
reported on july 14 that quote the bush
administration is being criticized by
some israeli and jewish communal
officials for calling on jerusalem not
to undermine the democratically elected
lebanese government end of quote
abraham foxman the head of the adl said
quote the administration and western
countries want to shore up the lebanese
government but it is a misguided policy
to do so and the same holds for abu
mazen they feel it's better that a
vacuum
they feel it's better than a vacuum but
you should not support what's
meaningless and we knew from day one
that abu mazen would go nowhere and that
the lebanese government would be
ineffective
not surprisingly bush stopped talking
about the need to protect the government
in beirut
lest you think that i'm making this up
it's worth noting that the key
organizations in the lobby have been
quite open and candid
in discussing their influence on u.s
policy during the lebanon war indeed it
is not an exaggeration to say that they
have boasted of it for example apex
president howard friedman wrote a letter
to friends and supporters of his
organization on july 30th which he began
by saying look what we've done
he then wrote quote only one nation in
the world came out and flatly declared
let israel finish the job
that nation is the united states of
america and the reason it had such a
clear unambiguous view of the situation
is you and the rest of american jewry
it is hardly surprising therefore that
prime minister ahood olmert recently
said
thank god we have aipac the greatest
supporter and friend we have in the
whole world
organizations like aipac were not the
only players in the lobby who were hard
at work during the recent conflict
journalists like charles krauthammer and
william crystal made the case to use
crystal's words that israel's war is
quote-unquote our war
the christian zionists also rallied
behind israel
the recently formed christians united
for israel held a two-day washington
israel summit here in the capital
in mid-july it attracted 3500 people and
participants were encouraged to express
their support for israel
by sending a loud and clear message to
their senators and representatives
the executive director of another group
the christian friends of israel
offered the rather unchristian insight
that quote this was certainly an
unprovoked attack and israel has every
right to go in and pound them
there are also a number of individuals
with deep attachments to israel and key
policy-making positions inside the bush
administration i've already
mentioned john bolton more importantly
the two most influential advisors on
middle east affairs in the white house
are both fervent supporters of israel
consider eliot abrams a senior director
at the national security council whose
devotion to israel is well established
not surprisingly the new york times
reported during the war that he quote
has pushed the administration to throw
its support behind israel the other key
figure is david wormser who was vice
president cheney's advisor on middle
east wormser who makes no bones about
his deep commitment to israel is one of
the main authors of the famous clean
break study written in 1996 for incoming
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu it advocated that israel and
end the oslo peace process process and
use military force to topple regimes
across the middle east and some it is
clear that
the lobby played a critical role in
shaping u.s policy toward israel and the
broader middle east during the recent
war between israel and lebanon
nevertheless it did so in ways that were
neither in america nor the israeli
national interest
now one might argue that washington's
unyielding support for israeli policy is
not the result of the lobby's influence
as we claim but is due to the fact that
the american people are deeply committed
to israel in other words israel gets
unconditional support because the u.s
public demands it
this line event of of argument is not
convincing for two reasons first it is
clear that american citizens are more
favorably disposed toward israel than
our citizens and other democracies but
this is hardly surprising
since the lobby is so successful at
controlling the discourse about israel
in the united states if there was an
open and freewheeling debate about the
jewish state public opinion here would
almost certainly be more in line with
european
and asian public opinion on israel
second
despite the one-sided discourse about
israel in the united states public
opinion is still surprisingly clear-eyed
when it comes to dealing with israel in
fact americans have a much more critical
view of israeli policy than government
officials do and they are certainly much
more hard-nosed in how they think about
dealing with israel
thus it is hard to argue that the
policies of the bush administration and
the behavior of congress reflect public
attitudes about israel
to elaborate let's look at some
representative survey data on four
critical issues related to the recent
war in lebanon on the question of who is
to blame for starting the conflict in an
abc news washington post poll conducted
on august
3-6
46 of the respondents said that israel
and hezbollah were equally to blame
that's 46 percent another 7 percent
blamed israel alone
on the question of whether israel has
gone too far in its attacks
a usa today gallup poll conducted on
july 21st to 23rd found that 38 of the
respondents said that they disapproved
of the military action israel has taken
in lebanon
on whether the united states should
support israel or remain neutral
in a cbs
news new york times poll conducted on
july 21 to july 25th
40 percent of the respondents said the
united states should not publicly
support either israel or hezbollah but
should say and do nothing
seven percent favored criticizing israel
and another 14 percent were unsure what
to do
39 favored supporting israel on whether
the united states and israel should
agree to an immediate ceasefire a july
19 2006 cnn poll found that 43 of the
respondents said that israel should
agree to a ceasefire
as soon as possible
in short there's a marked asymmetry
between how americans think about israel
and the recent conflict in israel and
what the u.s government has done thus
one cannot argue that the actions of the
bush administration and the congress
during the 33 day war were largely a
reflection of american public opinion
the second alternative explanation which
one sometimes hears is that the united
states is in fact the driving force
behind the war in lebanon and israel is
merely its client state
israel in other words is a loyal ally
doing the bush administration's dirty
work
there are two reasons to doubt this
claim first if this claim was true
israel's bombing offensive would have
been confined to southern lebanon and
great care would have been taken to
protect and strengthen the lebanese
government after all president bush made
it clear that the start of the crisis
that he did not want to endanger the
government in beirut
which he had worked so hard to install
more generally the united states almost
certainly would not have sought to set
lebanon back 20 years as called for by
israel's chief of staff
second there's actually little evidence
that the bush administration planned the
offensive and then pushed israel to
execute it in fact the available
evidence suggests
that israel had planned the lebanon
campaign in the months before the events
of july 12 which it used as a pretext
for launching it
israel undoubtedly briefed the united
states about the plan and got bush's
endorsement but giving israel the green
light is not the same as using israel as
a client state
in conclusion neither of the alternative
explanations can account for american
policy during the recent war in lebanon
nor can one find the compelling
strategic or moral rationale that
explains why the united states provided
israel with unyielding support while the
rest of the world criticized israeli
behavior in lebanon
in fact the lobby was the main driving
force behind u.s middle east policy as
it has been since the late 1960s
the war in lebanon has been a disaster
for the lebanese people
as well as a major strategic setback for
the united states and for israel
the lobby played a key role in enabling
israel's counterproductive response by
preventing the united states from
exercising independent influence
in this case as in so many others the
lobby's influence has been harmful to
u.s interests but also harmful to israel
as well
until the lobby begins to favor a
different approach
or until its influence is weakened
u.s policy in the region will continue
to be hamstrung
to everyone's detriment thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much we have about 15 to
20 minutes for questions so we'll get
started right off the bat
first question how can elected officials
be convinced to support a balanced
mideast policy when they do not gain
benefits from standing on principle and
i'd remind our panelists that we've been
asked to come to the podium and answer
questions
i think this is a very difficult
question and it's a very difficult
challenge because the institutions that
are currently arrayed to to
encourage support for israel are quite
powerful and quite well funded
and if you're a
congressman whose constituents don't
care one way or the other but a few of
your constituents care a lot and you
know that there's a lot of pac money
that will go to any of your opponents
you have trouble
so i think at least as a first step the
thing we want to have is a more open
conversation about this that's the main
reason why john and i have been doing
this work we want to try and get a
conversation so that politicians who do
unconditionally support israel down the
line start facing questions from their
constituents as to why they're doing
that
until they perceive a political price
for policies that aren't in the american
national interest they're likely to keep
doing this one way
in fact i think probably the best way to
try and instill that is to try and
educate the american people more broadly
educate members of the media more
broadly and again try and foster a
climate where we can have an open and
serious conversation about those issues
our second question what about the us
arms export and control act and the
neutrality act that bars
excuse me i'm trying to read someone
else's handwriting that bars americans
and the israeli army from attacking
friendly nations
well the problem with legislation like
that is that when you talk about what is
a friendly nation or what is an enemy
nation it's very easy to find spin
doctors who can define any particular
nation
as either a friend or a foe
depending on the particular
circumstances
so there are real limits to what you're
going to be able to do as a result of
formal legislation i think the real key
to making
american policy smarter is to create a
situation where american
leaders
are
more or less independent of pressures
from
organizations in the lobby
and can do what they think is in the
best interest of the united states
and if that situation obtains i think in
most cases american leaders will do the
smart thing for the united states and i
think in most cases certainly not all
cases that will redound to the benefit
not only of israel but other states in
the region i think and i think steve
made this point clear in his
presentation that if the united states
had been free of the lobby's influence
for most of the past three decades
we would have pushed politics in the
region in ways that would have created a
more peaceful environment this is not to
say for one second that we would have
produced nirvana in the area
steve and i are both realist we
understand that international politics
politics is a is a nasty and dangerous
business but on the other hand i think
if the united states had been more
independent in its foreign policy over
the past few decades we could have gone
a long way towards making the middle
east more stable than it is today which
again is not to say we would have made
it paradise on earth
our next question
what in your opinion was the turning
point for which aipac really began
controlling u.s foreign policy was it
under reagan
uh i i first of all i'd object to the
premise of the question i don't think
aipac controls foreign policy i think
again as i said in my remark i think
there's a very profound influence
particularly on
key issues in the middle east but i
think it's a mistake to to view this as
some kind of either secret cabal that
controls our foreign policy or it gets
its way on absolutely every issue
then if you now to answer the spirit of
the question not the exact wording of
the question i think if you look
historically uh aipac begins to have
substantially more influence after the
six day war when american support for
israel begins to increase and then it
really takes off i think in the 1980s
partly because of just internal reforms
within the organization it gets more
effective it does better jobs of
fundraising and things like that also
because it's becoming very adroit at
selling this strategic ally argument
which again at the height of the cold
war and especially in the reagan era you
could make a reasonably uh plausible
case so by the time the 1990s roll
around and the
cold war comes to an end it's
sufficiently well institutionalized
sufficiently effective and i might add
there have been enough sufficiently
well-publicized cases
of congressmen having their careers
ended because they advocated a position
that aipac didn't particularly like that
at that point it begins to really have a
very profound influence on american
foreign policy
next question you said that the u.s gave
israel a green light
to smash hezbollah
do you have hard evidence that the war
was premeditated
uh
there have been
a bevy of articles that have been
produced
which quote prominent israeli
strategists civilian strategists and
government insiders
who make it clear
that israel
feared hezbollah's missile threat and by
the way i think this is perfectly
understandable i think if any one of us
in the room was an israeli we would have
been deeply concerned about hezbollah's
missile threat so israel was looking at
this missile threat and it decided uh
that using military force against it
made sense
i find it hard to believe that people as
experienced in warfare as the israelis
could have been foolish enough to
believe that air power alone could have
taken out the hezbollah missiles much
less hezbollah but for some reason they
came to that conclusion that with air
power alone
israel could lance the boil
they came up with a plan and they
briefed it to the united states in the
weeks and months before july 12th and it
was made clear to the united states
that all that was needed was a pretext
to launch this air campaign to deal with
the missile threat and the israelis and
the americans and virtually everybody
else understood that there was enough
back and forth between hezbollah and
israel taking place over time that an
event would eventually come up that the
israelis could use
as a cover for launching this offensive
you want to remember i pointed out to
you that it was not hezbollah that first
started bombing
cities in northern israel it was the
israelis who first started bombing
civilian infrastructure in lebanon
because the israelis were loaded for
bear so to speak when the event happened
on july 12th so i think from everything
we know that's in the public record at
this point in time it seems
quite clear that israel had planned this
an event this offensive before july 12th
the next question is split up
with one for each of the professors
why did professor walt single out
wolfowitz and faith for blame and not
their non-jewish boss rumsfeld
and then the question to professor
mersheimer
what would have been an acceptable
response by israel to a raid on its
territory and missiles hitting its
cities
um
i uh singled out uh wolfowitz and fights
because i think they were critical
members in driving the case for war more
so than secretary of defense rumsfeld i
could have mentioned
non-jewish people like john bolton as
well who i think is a very strong
supporter of israel and was a big
advocate of going to war as well so this
wasn't a statement about being jewish
one way or the other was a statement of
what you were supporting in terms of how
to deal
with iraq
i didn't mention but i explicitly
mentioned to cheney and bush on the
other side that in the first
nine months of the bush administration
it's clear
from again what we've been able to read
in the public record that
wolfowitz was pushing for the united
states to take action against iraq but
he was unable to persuade bush that it
was a good idea and unable to persuade
cheney it was a good idea there's even
some reports i don't know how how
accurate they are that uh that bush was
starting to get annoyed by this that you
know wolf was kept bringing this up all
the time and he eventually gets told to
stop because it's getting on the
president's nerves
but the point is after september 11th
then the political stars realign a
little bit and bush and cheney come on
board which is why again we say the
lobby was a necessary condition for
getting the war absent its pressure you
wouldn't have had it they'd been pushing
it for a long time but absent 911 you
wouldn't have gotten the war in iraq
either that was critical to shaping the
political calculations
the question was
what excuse me do i think would have
been
an appropriate alternative response by
israel
uh
first of all i i think that israel
probably should have used some military
force against hezbollah in response to
what happened on july 12th i should
think it should have been much more
selective
and much more limited
in large part because using
massive military force was
counterproductive it just didn't make
good strategic sense and again i do not
understand why the israelis themselves
given all their experience fighting in
the middle east didn't understand this
but i think that using massive military
force the way they did between july 12th
and august 14th was a major mistake
should have been a much more limited
attack and they certainly should have
ramped down their rhetoric it was very
foolish to say that the principal goal
here is to destroy hezbollah and we're
going to do that and all we need is for
the united states to give us another
week or two to do that heck the israelis
were in lebanon for 18 years between
1982 and 2000 and they couldn't defeat
defeat hezbollah why in god's name did
they think that they could defeat
hezbollah from the air in three or four
weeks this was just not going to happen
so they should have had very limited
goals rhetorically they should have
given hezbollah a sharp wrap and that
should have been the end of it
and this will be the question that we
use to wrap up our session
how can american muslims arab americans
and people of other faiths
back our take back our foreign policy
and make it more balanced
boy and now you're expecting me to be a
real miracle worker
um
you know i i guess i'm a big uh believer
still in the basic roots of american
democracy and i believe that although
very powerful countries like the united
states can
can do things that are foolish for quite
some time without paying an enormous
price because we're big and powerful
ultimately the costs of those policies
do get recognized uh we're seeing the
costs of one of our follies every day in
iraq now costly for us costly for the
iraqi people dangerous for all countries
in the region so eventually reality does
start to to impose itself on our
consciousness i think what all americans
of different faiths and different
political backgrounds can do is demand a
little bit more of your elected
representatives
ask them harder questions inform
yourselves about different things that
are happening in the world
don't take one side as gospel
immediately and in particular do
everything you can to encourage an open
and sober debate
don't let people who have views you
might disagree with get marginalized or
smeared
recognize that one of the great
strengths of democracy is the fact that
we can argue about issues and i think
the more that that tends to happen in
the united states the more we're going
to see american foreign policy on this
and on many other issues revert to
something that's more consistent with
our broader national interests thank you
very much
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of the
council on american islamic relations
i'd like to thank you all very much
we have two particular groups to thank
and that is our panelists for being
willing to come down to washington today
to speak with us but equally thank you
very much because while what they have
to say is very important it's also very
important that people be out there
listening we appreciate it if you'd like
to learn more about the organization
please visit us at care.com thank you
[Applause]